good evening I'm Andrew Delbanco I'd
like to welcome you to tonight's program
I'll be very brief so as not to steal
time from the conversation I am wearing
three hats tonight if that's not too
grotesque a metaphor so I welcome you on
behalf of the center for american
studies which i direct here at columbia
the library of america on whose board it
is my great privilege to sit and the
Institute for Israel and Jewish Studies
to which I like to think I'm a friend
and as Jeremy Dalbir will certainly
agree in enthusiastic kibbitzer tonight
marks the second partnership event of
our three organizations and we
anticipate many more last year we
celebrated on this stage the publication
of Elan Stefan's wonderful book about
American immigrant writing with
conversation between jhumpa lahiri and
gary shteyngart this year we've
ratcheted up to three major figures of
the American theater in conversation
with Lawrence cenelec editor of this
wonderful book that we're celebrating
tonight the American stage writing on
theatre from Washington Irving to Tony
Kushner my colleague max Rudin publisher
of the library America will speak about
the book in a moment in planning
tonight's program we wanted of course to
cover the whole span of the book but we
were not able to get Washington Irving
whose agent told us what agents always
tell you when they don't like the terms
namely that mr. Irving had a previous
engagement but we're thrilled that Tony
Kushner tova feldjoe and Gregory Moshe
were free and willing to join us and
were grateful to all of them I want to
share just one note from the book which
I think helps explain the naturalness of
our partnership tonight it's from Tony's
very moving memorial essay about Arthur
Miller who's play a view from the bridge
as I'm sure you know has recently been
brilliantly reinterpreted by Greg mosher
in that essay Tony uses the phrase
demanding interior T to describe Miller
is imagination such interior tea is
hardly an exclusively Jewish theme but
it does help to explain why tonight's
program and sponsorship make sense to us
the book we celebrate is about American
culture in general about drama in
particular and not incidentally in my
view at least about the movement of Jews
from the periphery to the center of
American cultural life so let me offer
again a warm welcome thank you very much
for coming and i'll turn the podium over
to max
thanks Andy on behalf of America our
president Cheryl Hurley our directors
and staff welcome and thanks again to
andrew de blanco and jeremy dabur our
partners this evening as you may know
the Library of America is a non-profit
enterprise dedicated to making
permanently available authoritative
editions of great American writing and
several years ago we began talking to
Lauren cenelec about an idea he'd had
what would it be like to gather in one
place the incredibly diverse writing
about American theater not just about
drama as literature but open it up to
live theatrical performance as an
exhilarating shared experience available
to everyone a book where Eugene O'Neill
and David Mamet Barrymore's Hamlet and
Brando Stanley Kowalski would rub
shoulders with vaudeville burlesque and
melodrama Yiddish theater and the
chitlin circuit with hitmakers like
helping in heart grabbing the audience
with relentlessly honed rewrites and
staged business alongside experimental
troops grabbing the audience by well by
grabbing the audience a book in other
words that would match the wild and
wooly try anything and everything energy
of the American stage its sights it
sounds and it's pre Civil War beginnings
even it's whiskey tinge smells the only
criteria was that the writer had to have
first-hand experience of the magic of
the theater on either side of the
footlights and the gift to express and
reflect it in writing that feels alive
the result several years later is this
book edited with style wit and daunting
erudition by Lawrence who was Fletcher
professor of drama and oratoria tops and
who this past summer became the first
theater scholar elected to the american
academy of arts and sciences there are
many pleasures in the book as you'll
discover for one the behind-the-scenes
look at legendary productions like John
law on his father Bert the great
burlesque comedian who went on to
grapple with the
estragon in the broadway premiere of
Waiting for Godot the director meanwhile
tearing his hair out trying to convince
Bert Lahr that in this kind of show
there isn't really such thing as a top
banana it's the rare case of a book
where the editors notes are informative
and entertaining as the text itself
OneNote provides a one-paragraph whistle
stop tour of American melodrama
including the first father to turn an
erring daughter out into this into a
snowstorm and the first utterance of the
line quick this house and never darken
the threshold of its door again in fact
I was thinking before tonight's event
that it might just be possible from the
notes to this book to actually construct
a timeline of American theater in one
liners which I didn't have time to do
but I will just offer you one example
for the 1930s radical play right
Clifford Odette's quits the Communist
Party to write for the movies
screenwriter Frank newgen responds to
his new work Odette's where is thy sting
taken together the 78 men and women in
American stage tell a new kind of
first-hand history of theatre in America
a richer and more various story than
were used to but they also speak to us
for another reason maybe a deeper reason
because they speak in a familiar
American accent of old mysteries how
something so evanescent as if the
optical performance can be more deeply
and more indelibly memorable than our
lived lives how theater can be both a
wonderful festival a daydream factory
and also what Arthur Miller calls a
doorway through which the great answers
wait Miller in the book tells a story
about death of a salesman Ali Jacob SAT
like a lump all through rehearsals heavy
eyed morose a morning walrus as hell nor
describes him then one afternoon he rose
from his chair looked at newly donec
playing Linda and everything went silent
and then he said
I was driving along you understand then
all of a sudden I'm going off the road
Miller rights and the theater vanished
the stage vanished the chill of an
age-old recognition shuttered my spine
what you might call the deep history of
the American stage is written in moments
like these the memory of them the
reverence for them the dream to create
and be part of them they are of course
in the collaborative art of a theater
born of the combined gifts of actor
director and playwright we have the
incredible good fortune to have joining
Lawrence Santa like on the stage tonight
one of each three of the most
extraordinarily gifted theatre people of
this or any generation like O'Neill and
Williams before him preeminent American
playwright Tony Kushner is constantly
breaking new theme attic and stylistic
ground and like Arthur Miller before him
defining what it means to be a political
playwright in the largest sense for our
place and time his seminal masterpiece
Angels in America is about to be revived
by the Signature Theatre Company
acclaimed award-winning stage and screen
actress tova fell choo is living proof
that artistic integrity and star power
can cohabit in one person she has
triumphed in roles ranging from Yentl to
Tallulah Bankhead not to mention as
golden maer in the longest-running
one-woman show in broadway history
through October thirty-first she stars
in the nora and delia ephron hit love
loss and what I wore at the westside
theatre Gregory Moser has directed and
produced over 200 plays on Broadway and
off here and abroad and won every major
theatre award he's worked with Tennessee
Williams and Samuel Beckett among many
other of our greatest playwrights and
actors and perhaps best known for his
legendary collaborations with David
Mamet professor of theatre at Columbia
and director of its Arts Initiative it
took a little time off in the past year
to mount an acclaimed revival of Arthur
Miller's of you from the bridge which
earned him a 2010 Tony nomination for
Best Director
please welcome tova fell chu tony
kushner Gregory Mosher and Lauren
cenelec
what I'd like to do tonight is create a
kind of dialogue between the past and
the present we have here what is the
creation of a new theatre when I was a
young actor I was once told that
anything you do in the theater twice
becomes a tradition and tradition is
what the anthology is very much about
the anthology is in fact a creation of
people who from the very beginnings of
the American theater although they may
have been unaware of it were putting
down footprints that others were
following and those others were then
diverging into other paths and the whole
thing gets braided into what we now see
as the contemporary American theater
represented by the people on this stage
so what I'm going to suggest tonight is
a very informal conversation I am going
to throw out a topic or a question and
ask the panelists to respond to it they
and I have picked out some passages in
the book from the past in which those
topics may be addressed so you'll hear
the dead and the living together and the
river a question I do want to throw out
is tradition so often when you enter a
rehearsal room when you begin to write a
play you are told you can or can't do
this or that because it isn't what used
to be done and I was wondering if any of
you have come across that experience of
either finding a tradition that was
helpful to you or a tradition that stood
in your way no particular order anybody
who wants to respond i was trained by
Michael Langham at the Guthrie Theater
and to buy by British by British
phenomenal director very very tough he
hazed oh I was McKnight fellow I carried
Spears and under studied all the leading
ladies who were saw
seven and that time it was Roberta
Maxwell and Dianne Wiest and in all
events we learn things like feel good
saying lifted so I can take it that are
my obligation of my obligation tonight
is to make sure that I'm audible so I
assume you can all understand me yeah
that's very important that's the core of
my job is to make sure that my vowels
and consonants are in order so that you
can apprehend what I'm trying to
communicate to you with the advent of
reality TV and the advent of movie stars
coming to Broadway some of whom are very
skilled some of whom are not skilled at
all for the stage things have started to
happen with the audibility of different
acting styles and particularly in choral
pieces for instance in love loss and
what i wore there are pieces called the
clothesline pieces we're all five
actresses have to go along and if you
have somebody purely from a TV tradition
what sometimes happens is that the
bottom drops when that person takes the
ball because they do not pitch it with
the intent to include a room of i would
say around 200 people tonight maybe
slightly more but my intention is that
beige wall and that was taught to me by
Langham so that's a particular example
of how unamplified there still has to be
intent to include and that has changed
in my career that would be if you were
inaudible to Guthrie forget about it
she were out of there you know so this
is a different acting style and on the
other hand we don't de claim the way to
people who did the dells art technique
did the coming of Lee Strasburg in the
studio made the interior experience of
the actor much clearer to a whole
generation of actors starting with for
me Brando eli wallach and jackson and
then we were their children who were
their children I have been feeling I was
a graduate student directing at NYU and
it was a text teacher doing or a gun
feat who died you know I know I had
Edith warm and Skinner from the
Juilliard she's I'd like sort of cut the
same cloth yes Nora if you are a curious
you can see you Netflix Forrest Gump
she's be older than sitting on the bench
listening to Tom Hanks and she's an
amazing a text teacher and I am sort of
technique of teaching text by driving
people crazy she teach you today how to
say the the unencumbered another example
of did you deal with our coloring like
aa coloring agreeing the green grass you
should say what kind of grass is the
green grass what kind of grass the green
grass if you've a computer of indigo
what was green the grass and read it
over and over and over again and I feel
I steady playwriting within
really I mean I took six weeks of
classes with jean-claude man italia
posture in the water that in Brooklyn he
was advertising crisis and Ike report
but uh but I feel that their work with
Nora on textual specificity with
enormous help and it's a if that's also
i think in addition to your projection
and why using consonants and vowels in a
certain way there's a textual
specificity that I think you've got lost
to a certain degree and I think that
it's for text heavy work an incredibly
important ingredient in when I first
came in New York I was in the
mid-seventies until I arrived into the
glory days of American about guard
theater accommodation I think mr. group
and Babu mines and robert wilson at
richard forman we're doing over hello
the most excited mortgage naked the
everything it was a little bit earlier
but checking was still around and doing
saw a few things that even was
production of em getting I manhattan
theatre club which was one of the
greatest things I've ever seen so but I
didn't tell drew many rules that needs
to be obeyed because i'm going to make
so many extraordinary things that simply
define all categories sorry i never help
particularly found in my tradition you
had to be heard movies before I remember
when Jack Lemmon was the first movie
star I saw amplified in a play it was
like it was like a scandal you were
never amplified in a play really weren't
maybe there were Mike's here but in
1973-74 I did the Cyrano with Chris
plumber and Chris plumber was body mine
but nobody else was body minds maybe
because plumber and Roxanne that was it
miss was a Broadway musical at the
palace by 74 we did rogers and hard it
was all singing we were all body Mike
but then I did yet till we were never
might never you know it was unheard of
it's interesting that miking plumber and
nobody else is actually part of a
tradition a very old actor who had
worked with Henry Irving told me that
when Irving in the 1890s had a major
speech he wanted to deliver he would
come downstage center and he would stomp
on the stage that was to tell the gas
man to turn up the flares in the
footlights so that he would be lit more
at that moment than anybody else Greg I
I came into the theater in the 60s so
the whole thing was to get rid of
tradition and the people you've just
mentioned and so was i might like my
private life i was reading everything I
did soon in all the 19th century writers
and trying to learn from them but when I
would get into the rehearsal room it was
down with downwards down with Miller
down with Williams Odette it was
Odette's nobody cared about of debt and
it was only later that I came back to
understand how how great these people
were I was well into my bag I only
wanted to do new place but do you find
that a loss that there a tradition that
people have grown up in and also there's
a disk at all there's a discontinuity
and it happened during that period it
seems to me there's no sense I have
students who have never read a streetcar
named desire I mean we're not talking
about no streetcar cold the way a
musician would know what the elbows are
doing in the third movement of
Beethoven's seventh they just haven't
read it and what does I know instead um
they know contemporary playwrights and
no Tony they know right no but they know
writers were writing now they can go see
but to go and read a book to go to the
library to take 15 plays home with you
and that's this week's reading in
addition to your regular class work
that's gone I think
little acquainted American the other
theater students are with European
riders like hina Muller I think some of
the most famous like better than
sometimes Breck the whole you know
anything that's pretty twenty centuries
forget about the New Orleans read the
Schiller nose right yeah and that's
terrible there's also very little
opportunity to see any of that on stage
one of the interesting that was that in
the in that period of autism I mean
there were you know the Wooster group
was doing a series of you know radical
reinterpretations of American classics
but I actually first became interested
again in Arthur Miller during the
controversy over LSD just the high
points when Miller Liz become Wooster
group did is absolutely astonishing
production it was in some ways would
have pasted on is that kind of
accommodation for carpet earrings of
young McCarthy hearings and the crucible
which is detective using an Arthur
stepped in and stopped the production
right always had a certain time when I
was in high school everybody over to
dramatic readings from the crucible so I
have an allergy to the play should have
gotten as you were saying everything was
breakfast with me so unfamiliar was just
this tedious old American sell out and I
was a college student and then I I
thought well why would somebody as smart
as it wasn't the comp forget the
students the crucible and I wasn't was
into some of the worlds that lies that
they were playing around with you
production and I went back and I reread
the crucible but oh my god this is an
extraordinary blood and then I started
rereading all it wasn't me entirely just
continuous thing it was a maybe this is
a good segue great oh we're so milord up
already thank you Lawrence asked us to
choose a night I thought I'd go for a
back shot and do Toni on Arthur but now
I didn't think you were going to come to
me right away here we go this is the
last essay in the book so we're working
as we often do and I'm skipping around a
little bit Arthur demanded that we must
be able to answer on behalf of our plays
our endeavors our lives a really tough
question one that Arthur wrote was the
chief and in a sense only reason for
writing and speaking what is its
relevancy he asked to the survival of
the race not he stipulates the American
race or the Jewish race for the German
race but the human race he demanded that
our work and our lives have some
relevance to human survival the question
implies anxiety I don't think my mics on
is it can you hear it is yes good um
sorry to screw up your prize he demanded
that our work and our lives have some
relevance to human survival the question
implies anxiety about that survival a
refusal of complacency an acknowledgment
that there is human community for which
each of us bears responsibility and a
warning that we are in danger Miller
tells us that what we do the things we
choose to struggle with an art and
elsewhere can have some effect on the
outcome there is in other words reason
to hope and change is possible Arthur
was a grieving pessimist but what truly
grouped progressive person isn't I think
I'll leave it for there right now
one of the things that come up in this
discussion so far with the lack of
cultural background on the part of
students in this case is what audiences
bring to a show one of the individuals i
discovered in putting together this
anthology was someone named Charles king
Newcombe who was a kind of fellow
traveler with the transcendentalists in
New England and then moved to
Philadelphia and kept a diary as a
bachelor and he keeps talking about
going to seeing Shakespeare and in the
course of a year he can see Hamlet
innumerable times with different actors
and he knows the script cold if they
change a word he puts it down in his
diary and since aha they didn't use the
word whore they used the word harlot and
even in the 20s you get stark young
writing a wonderful critique of John
Barrymore tablet and he's able to
compare it to any number of Hamlet's
he'd seen up to that point how many
people do you imagine would have seen a
production of view from the bridge in
order to compare it to yours but then it
falls off after that and and that's a
mixed blessing yeah you know you wanted
to be seen in perspective but how
wonderful to have someone come and know
and figure out 20 minutes in this guy
that's a pretty great how great to see
how he's going to die a dream I suppose
so the the blank slate audience right
tova would you like to read the piece
about epson because I think that fits
you are nicely I realized as we're
talking I I was originally a classical
pianist and I think early in my life I
had great faith in the classics so I
went to Sarah Lawrence to balance offer
remember Dean Fitzgerald at scars oh hi
saying go to Sarah Lawrence I was
accepted to Vassar and Smith and
rejected at Holyoke and anyway go to
Sarah Lawrence it's so creative in your
creative and Bubba Bubba so I went to
Sarah Lawrence when my mother came Joe
Chaiken was my teacher we did Renard the
Fox by stirred
skia had a green wig and purple teeth
and my mother said to me Chava why
didn't you go to Vassar I'll never god
she's going to be a hundred my mother
okay this is a dialogue between
Alexander Wolcott and one of his
favorite actresses mrs. Fiske about
epson mrs. Fiske says how can we
persuade people to turn back to the
plays and reread them for the color the
romance the life that there's in them
we're in all the world of modern drama
for instance is there a comedy so
buoyant so dazzlingly joyous as an enemy
of the people they say he's parochial
says Alexander Wolcott let them say it
says mrs. Fiske they said it of Hedda
but that poor empty little Norwegian
neurotic has been recognized all over
the world the trouble with had a is not
that she's parochial but that she is
poor and empty she was fascinating to
play and I suppose that every actress
goes through the same phase of being
especially attracted by such characters
a part of the phase when the eagerness
to study life takes the form of an
interest in the eccentric abnormal
distorted the perverted aspects of life
as a whole that's how it's written and
as they evolve with the circumflex
header is a marvelous portrait as a
person she's empty after all the empty
evil selfish persons are not worth our
time either yours or mine in the theater
anymore than in life they do not matter
they do not count they're enormously
unimportant on the highway of life the
head of gobblers are just so much
impedimenta do you recall says Alexander
Wolcott that that is the very word
Caesar used for baggage we're at mrs.
Fisk smiled so approvingly that I knew
poor Hedda would be impedimenta to the
end of the chapter but she is universal
says mrs. Fisk she was recognized all
over the world London saw her at every
dinner table and I have watched a great
auditorium in the Far West of place as
large as our metropolitan
enthralled by that brilliant comedy and
there we have it go figure one of my
intentions when I put together this
anthology after all it's for the Library
of America the Library of America is
meant to be a repository of the best
American writing so I was looking for
pieces that were exceptionally well
written and entertaining to read book
aloud and to oneself and that became
harder and harder as I got closer and
closer to the contemporary theater
because many of the middlebrow magazines
of the past for which much of this
writing was done no longer exists
because the readership no longer exists
this may be invidious but I picked up
recently that big anthology via of
American theater the magazine 25 years
of American theater and half the book is
interviews now I included two interviews
in the anthology one of the interviews
was by one of the inventors of the forum
allendale in late 19th century and it's
a very clever interview of Clara Morris
where he walks a kind of knife edge
between respect and sarcasm the other
was the one the Toba just read excerpts
from in which Alexander Woollcott turns
an interview with mrs. Fiske into a
one-act play basically a conversazione a
if there was a wonderful asset nowadays
interviews are simply transcriptions
from recorded nobody manipulates them
turns them into little works of art now
I was wondering if in general here we
bring up the issue of critics whether
you have found that writing about the
theater has changed over the course of
your careers well I don't know if the
writing has but thrillingly the media
has when I came to Broadway in the 70s
you lived and died over 1 review 1 there
was a monopoly I can't even describe it
73 when Cyrano opened there were eight
shows on Broadway we were in a recession
and if you didn't get the imprimatur of
the times you were screwed that was it
and then people like Barry and Fran why
slur good merchants figured out how to
market their plays no matter what the
reviews were no matter what and certain
plays that were not critical hits became
commercial hits which for an actor
foreign actor is a wonderful thing
because we give our time and our love
and our energy to something that we
don't prejudge is a hit or a flop you
give it your best shot no matter what
and actually I find I don't know if
there's an even or field of play but it
seems to me that there are more opinions
with the coming of the internet and
blogging and Twitter and Facebook where
you can merchan you can sell your
product not through the old channels
likewise of course television I don't
know if that doesn't answer your
question about writing but it answers it
about no but it does already open
another question which is his opinion
the same as criticism I was just going
to talk about engagement when I went to
Chicago in 1974 because I could not get
a job in New York I had just left school
there were five theater companies
counting the dinner theater where you
could get a show in dinner for eleven
dollars and the Gabor sisters came to
town and they ratcheted up to $13 which
prompted a critic planning Kleinfeld to
run into the members have been thirteen
dollars to see the goobers you can sleep
with them for eight
and I five years d theatre companies
five years after that their companies
and if anyone in this room I'm sure
knows they're probably 200 theater
companies in Chicago now three people
aside for money who was writing for the
reader were essential for that Glenna
sighs who wrote for the sun-times Linda
whiner who's now in New York and dick
Christensen and they went to every
storefront and they covered you as if
you were mrs. Fiske and they just didn't
care and that's why there is an American
Buffalo and and that's why there's a
Steppenwolf theatre company because they
just tried to the northern suburbs or
the south side or some little moose Hall
work and they covered it covered with
love and there would be no chicago
theatre at least those four people
bubbly others I mean Roger Denver I mean
you go Donell is it serious David will
tell you this that step invoke an
opinion isn't the same as criticism of
course not of course not the question is
where does the power reside and how how
do we get asses in the seats as that's
that's that's the job of the producer
Tony what did you read growing up about
the theater rather than just play the
scenes derrieres if you prefer I'm in
silk tonight yo I am
I have to say the only people who wanted
this book to be just about critics are
critics here's a Melville in his novel
Marty which has been a dry run for Moby
Dick but passage it says you wonder why
he got so many been abusing us by the
other passage with he says the critics
are like I really couldn't read it well
they create some I mules trample a rose
garden and then mistake the crushed
fragrance of the roses for their own
right well maybe you want to read them
everybody okay well i'm about to happy
with you and all play 20 year old fight
opening at the signature angels in
america it and the pics are coming soon
so I I was really happy when to be an
intelligent writers ever I want to read
to find this message heroic love by Mary
McCarthy he's a writer I really admire
it enormously but who was a drama
criticism for the nation and got it
wrong on a couple of occasions this is
her review streetcar called success it's
a review a streetcar named desire you
are an ordinary guy and her wife's
sister comes to stay with you whenever
you want to go to the toilet there she
is in the bathroom crimping or having a
bath or giving herself a shampoo and
taking her time about it you go and
hammer on the door for Christ's sakes
aren't you through yet and your wife
shush with you frowning Lee Blanche is
very sensitive and you must be careful
of her feelings you get sore at your
wife your kidneys are sensitive to my
dog in the whole wide enough so that
Blanche can hear you can demand pee in
his own house when and when is she
getting out of it you are pretty sick
too of feeling or criticize your table
manners and vision
to turn on the radio when you were
having a poker game who does she think
she is finally you and your wife have a
fight you knew all along that she was
turning a little woman against you you
decide to put your foot down Blanche
will have to go your wife reluctantly
gives in anything for peace don't think
it's been a treat for her but let me
handle it Stanley after all she's my own
sister one way or another god knows what
your wife told her Blanche gets the idea
you buy our ticket home but then right
at the end when you're carrying your
bags downstairs for you feel sort of
funny maybe you were too hard that's the
way the world is employee isn't it great
to be alone this variation on the
mother-in-law theme is the one solid
piece of theatrical furniture that a
streetcar named desire can show the rest
is an epic asserts acrimony and umbrage
tears door slamming broken dishes jeers
cold silences whispers raised eyebrows
the determination take no notice the
whole class of paraphernalia of insult
and injury is Tennessee Williams hope
chest that the domestic dirty linen
contains generally associated with the
comic strip and the radio sketch should
not invalidate it for having a subject
matter it has nobler antecedents the
cook one may recall is leaving on the
opening page of Anna Karenina and Hamlet
at the court of Denmark is really
playing the part of the wife's unwelcome
relation Dickens Dostoevsky foul rattle
the skeleton the family life there is no
limit apparently to what people will do
to each other in the family nothing
too grotesque or shameful all laws are
suspended including the law of
probability mr williams at his best is
an outrageous writer in this category
and his worst is outrageous in another i
even had he been content in the
streetcar named desire with the
exasperated trivia of the in-laws story
he might have produced a wonderful comic
epic the struggle for the bathroom
rippled and poignant a comedy um William
which would have not been deficient
either in those larger implications to
which his town presumes to the bathroom
either figured is the last Fortress of
the individual the poor man's club the
working girls temple of beauty and the
bathtub in the toilet symbol of illusion
and symbol of fact the throne and the
upright the female of the male might
have faced each other eternally in blank
porcelain contradiction at the area for
self-expression contracted to the limit
of his windowless cell mr. Williams
however like the southern women he
writes about appears to have been
mortified by the literary poverty of
such material by the pettiness of the
arena and which is in fact its grandeur
like Blanche DuBois in streetcar named
desire and the mother in a glass
menagerie he is addicted to the
embroidering lie and though his taste in
fancy work differs from these ladies in
climbing board of the modernistic the
stark contrast the jagged seeing the
jungle motifs and then parentheses then
they come together with low animal
moments which is all just a graduate but
the tourists mexican flores para los
muertos coronas para los muertos de
clarinet music suicide homosexuality
rape and insanity his work creates in
the end that very effect of painful
falsity which is imparted to the
Kowalski has no household by Blanche's
pink lampshades and couch covers I could
go on but I want she also got Iseman
kind of wonderfully wrong in the same
subjects I put that in there to show how
even a really keen intelligence can get
something wrong as a critic and I
juxtaposed it is the very next piece
with harold clurman analysis of the
first production of streetcar named
desire
Clurman pronounces it a masterpiece body
says cousins production is wrong very
interesting because we tend to think of
that production as the definitive one
and he says basically marlon brando is
the most sensitive actor early American
stage you don't put him in the role of a
brute a neo-fascist because we then
identify with Stanley and not with
Blatche particularly when the actors in
that case Jessica Tandy is not as strong
as the actor opposite so there is
another unorthodox viewpoint but coming
from a very logical consideration of the
play and not quite us by Jupiter 2 as
McCarthy's which brings us actually I
think to the question of actors and
actresses and the balances on stage one
of the things that you can discover
going through this anthology
historically is how the actress gains
respectability little by little how it's
very hard for respectable young women to
go on the stage they're considered
whores and perhaps you'd like to read a
bit of olive Logan's my diatribe against
the leg show in the 1860s yes when she
gave up her career she then dedicated
herself to women's rights nudity on the
stage let me just give you all of
Logan's technology was 1839 and she died
in 1909 her favorite topics were equal
rights for women and the condemnation of
what she called the lake business
regarding nudity on the stage clothed in
the dress of an honest woman she is
worth nothing to a manager stripped as
naked as she dare and it seems there is
little left when so much is done she
becomes a prize to her manager who knows
that crowds will rush to see her and who
pays her a salary accordingly there are
certain accomplishments which rendered
the nude woman more valuable to managers
in the degree that she possesses them I
will tell you what these accomplishments
are you shall judge how far they go
toward making her in any true
and actress they are number one the
ability to sing number two the ability
to jig number three the ability to play
on certain musical instruments to sing
yes but not to sing as paratha I guess
that must have been an opera star sings
nor such songs as she sings the songs in
demand in this sphere are vulgar sense
listen to be most triumphantly
successful should be capable of indecent
constructions and accompanied by the
wink the wriggle the grim ace which are
not peculiar to virtuous women whatever
else they are the more senseless the
song the more utterly it is idiotic
drivel the better it will answer in the
absence of the baser requisites here's a
specimen Little Bo Peep she lost her
sheep and don't know where to find her
leave her alone and she'll come home and
fetch her tail be haha hind her a simple
nursery song and if men were babies
innocent and harmless in itself but men
are not babies and the song is not sung
in a simple or harmless matter but with
the wink and the idiotic stare that
means a world and sets the audience into
an ecstatic roaring to jig let no one
can found jig dancing with the poetry of
motion which is illustrated by a
thoroughly organized and thoroughbred
body as ballet dancers the ability to
jig is an accomplishment which any of
these nude creatures can pick up in a
few weeks and finally the ability to
play a certain musical instrument these
instruments should be such as to look
queer in a woman's hands such
instruments as the banjo and the buccal
that's what so much for gypsy yeah so
much for wardrobe now exactly Olive
Logan was not alone in this attitude
that what we now see as the origins of
much musical comedy was particularly
salacious and much of it was meant to be
I have
an important story alil open in 1974 I
did a play called Yentl by Isaac singer
at bam and it would travel to Broadway
to the eugene o'neill theatre produced
by Victor Potemkin a Potemkin path
Cadillac oh mos ft and in person
impresario of the philly pops and and
Cheryl Crawford one of the founders of
the actors studio and the play demanded
that I lift my shirt up I was 22 23
years old lift my shirt up at the climax
of the play and I would not do it I
would not do it I remember quoting Liv
Ullmann saying my breasts are not fact
rissas and I remember offering to the
director god bless him to stand with my
breasts facing up States and to be
barebacked so that john shea could see
my breasts but a thousand people in the
o'neill theatre couldn't so he wanted to
replace me and the producers wouldn't
have it they wouldn't have it so fake
breasts were built on top of my breasts
and I was to show the fake breasts every
night it was on by Carrie Robbins and I
remember lifting that sits eat the the
fringe and I remember going like this
and every night the director would send
the note back I cannot see your breasts
and I would write him back come to my
dressing room
and and and and I remember feeling so
strong as an actor and I'm no I'm not
religious though it's often pinned on me
I'm not particularly religious or
fundamentals and like that but I knew
that if I was naked at the climax of the
play that they wouldn't hear the text
they wouldn't hear what was happening
and you know it was the real it was a
real problem the only problem I've had
with nudity ever since i have since call
that director were great friends and i
said i'm 30 odd years older let's do a
revival of Yentl i've got about three
weeks left to show my breasts publicly i
had a friend who was in the original
cast of hair and he said that every
night when the nude scene happened you'd
hear this odd quick throughout the
audience and finally figured out what it
was it was the opera glasses hitting the
eyeglasses have either of you gentlemen
censorship stories will I know you've
got plenty of censorship stories
paid my rent
for 20 years um speaking of hair i think
it was the first time was set on an
American stage and it's a laugh that
goes for nothing in this production that
just happened but one of the guys
wandered down stage and said it's
raining well it's raining and
this gasp through the house it's
raining and the the of it's just the
word right it was Lenny Bruce which
they're years years years before I got
to a Broadway stage but there was a all
of most of the reviews most of the
reviews of american buffalo were if you
took some version of if you took the
profanity out it would last three
minutes but here we are I mean and vomit
often says the difference between the
70s in the at the time he said it the
90s was in the 70s you went into a
drugstore and said I'd like three packs
of camels and some trojans and then the
90s you said I looked three packs of
Trojans
Danny would you like to contribute to
that okay we're drawing briefly well
we'll have a final round but I've asked
to announce that audience members who
want to ask questions should take index
cards and write them down in the
collective at hand it up so the index
cards are coming around I would like to
read a poem by don marcos and then we'll
have maybe the last statements before
the question period all right this is a
poem from his archean majida bell
theories some of you may be very
familiar with this Archie was a
cockroach who inhabited a newsroom in
the 1920s and late at night after hours
he would crawl onto a typewriter and
type out these poles but of course he
couldn't manage the shift key so they're
all in lowercase and they're all just
down the middle of the page and they're
usually about his friend majida Bell who
is an alley cat of low morals and high
spirits and this one is called the old
trooper I ran onto my head I bail again
last evening she's inhabiting a decayed
trunk which lies in an alley in
Greenwich Village in company with the
most villainous Tomcat I have ever seen
but there's nothing wrong about the
Association Archie she told me it is
merely a plutonic attachment and the
thing can be believed for that Tom looks
like one of plutos demons it is a
theater trunk and tom is an old theater
cat he has given his life to the theater
he claims that Richard Mansfield once
kicked him out of the way and then cried
because he had done it and petted him
and at another time he says in a case of
emergency he played a bloodhound in a
production of Uncle Tom's Cabin the
stage is not what it used to be tom says
he puts his front paw on his breast and
says they don't have it anymore they
don't have it here the old troopers are
gone there's nobody control anymore
they're all amateurs nowadays they
haven't got it here there are only five
or six of us old-time troopers left this
generation does not know what stage
presence is what personality is what
they lack personality where would they
get the training my old friends got in
the stock companies I knew mr. booth
very well as Tom and the law should be
passed preventing anybody else from ever
playing an Emmy play he ever played in
there was a trooper for you I used to
sit on his knee and / when I was a
kitten he used to tell me how much he
valued my opinion finish is what they
lack finish and they haven't got it here
began he laid his porn is rest I
remember mr. Daley very well too I was
with mr. Daly's company for several
years there was hard for you there was
teamwork there was direction they knew
the theater and they all had it here for
two years mr. Daley would not ring up
the curtain unless I was in the
prompters box they are amateurs nowadays
who rank amateurs all of them for two
seasons I played the dog in Joseph
Jefferson's Rip Van Winkle it is true I
never came on the stage but he knew I
was just off and it helped him I would
like to see one of your modern theatre
cats act a dog so well
that it would convince a trooper like
Joe Jefferson not they haven't got it
nowadays they haven't got it here Joe
Jefferson had it he had it here I come
of a long line of theater cats my
grandfather was with forest he had it he
was a real trooper my grandfather said
he had a voice that used to shake the
ferry boats on the North River once he
lost his beard and my grandfather
dropped from the fly gallery and landed
under his chin and played his beard for
the rest of the Act you don't see any
theater cats that could do that nowadays
they haven't got it they haven't got it
here once I played the owl in mo
Jessica's production of macbeth i SAT
above the castle gate in the murder
scene and made my yellow eyes shine
through the dusk like an owl's eyes
majesco was a real trooper she knew how
to pick her support and we'd like to see
any of these modern theater cats play
the Owls eyes to modjeska as Lady
Macbeth but they haven't got it nowadays
they haven't got it here mahira Bell he
says both our professions are being
ruined by amateurs so I would like to
hear from you what you feel about the
present state of the acting profession
all of you because you're off dealing
with actors one way or another how are
they trained do the other other risks
just so scary how many good actors
they're all right now you're you're
you're spoilt for choice really not that
you can get the person you need to be in
the plane you need that person to be in
it the time you're doing the play you're
always tearing your hair out about that
but um it's a wonderful time for America
not a night to what do you attribute
this I don't know I guess for the young
actors they're inspired by people like
Sean Penn was you know truly great actor
it's it's tradition I think I think
about way to the beginning but we are I
Lawrence I think and and and I and I and
I guess that's what I want to close with
if if you miss it by a generation you
know there was a moment in the late 80s
in 1989 when Steven Soderbergh made Sex
Lies and videotape and a lot of really
talented kids said whatever he's doing I
want to be doing that and there was this
as with his name said in milk campaign a
long time ago whooshing sound right as
everyone rushed off to be part of this
independent film movement and then it
turned out that that's the most
Orwellian term in a long time there is
no independent film in America and and
young people started to come back but
except for that moment of discontinuity
it's that you always want to connect and
if someone inspires it doesn't have to
be shown there million Peters it could
be but but you want you want that I
think it's why we go into it partly is
you want to be part of a ever wanted
could you do it for me I this is another
part of the of the toning thing I want
to read and at the risk of embarrassing
Tony it's silly to say who the best
playwright is but you know Tony's are
most important to play right and where
does that come from I've thought about
this sorry of embarrassment right before
the reviews too that'll come back to
haunt the both of us but but it's just
true and and I've thought so much about
where that comes from and I know you
know what inspired to David and other
people to do it but there's a little
thing from the same essay I first saw
Arthur Miller in person at the 1994 Tony
Awards when i SAT behind him to unnerved
to introduce myself for the whole
evening I stayed at the back of his head
which was far far more interesting to me
than anything transpiring on stage
inside this impressive cranium never had
a huge hit
inside this impressive cranium inside
this dome I thought to myself Willy
Loman was conceived for an American
playwright a place comparable and
sacrosanct ax t to the Ark of the
Covenant or the blow tea tree or the
manger in Bethlehem I wanted to touch
the head but I worried its honor might
have checked I'm going all the way back
to the beginning you want to be a part
of something you know there was a
perfectly OK playing on blue weight
plate where while ago when i asked my
lord what he thought of it and i thought
he was going to say piece of junk piece
of junk and he said you know what the
only problem with that play is there had
20 plays just like it because the fact
of the matter is the idiots from Long
Island I think he said um can't tell the
difference between this and streetcar
and here's the beauty part he said but
if you were 19 year old and about there
and you thought i can write him play
than that and in a way that's been
what's lost but it's the same impulse to
stare at Arthur's head and wonder how
Willy Loman came out of that flesh and
bone and synapses firing is a great
thing and the risk of sounding
flattering I'm really glad you tested
this because I think that's an important
thing of course Tony now has to worry
about who's sitting behind him yes dov'
I free with Greg and I I think the
reason there's such a wellspring of
ability is again back to the
communications that the communication
highway has has burgeoned I as an actor
when I research Tallulah Bankhead when I
researched Sarah burn on a plate Sarah
Bernhardt i went to the fifth floor
lincoln center i was allowed in there
were very certain stringent rules and
there was a woman named betty whose last
name escapes me at the moment who ran it
was wonderful to me and i watched the
few minutes of footage they have on
Bernhardt again and again and again and
i went into certain files and saw our
original documents but today when I'm a
scholar at the Museum of television and
broadcast in the study Tallulah Bankhead
to study golden a year to study Stella
Adler these are all when I played you
know you just call ahead the stuff is
ready boom boom boom
I came here to the library Columbia and
had nine hours of tape transferred from
the museum of tolerance to new york city
of your Dana Goethe Updike and spent my
days at Columbia University and it took
a minute to arrange it so the
information highway is so much more
available I also remember starting on I
went to Sarah Lawrence and that was a
McKnight fellow that about three
theatres where they paid for my Master's
I never wrote my thesis at the
University of Minnesota but the great
actors I work but they were as my they
were according to my parents um my
parents standard uneducated because I
didn't go to university a lot of them
came out of high school from Canada and
went right to stratton they were
extraordinary their extraordinary actors
but it's become the schools in the my
lifetime have become codified Yale and
Julie yard and Carnegie Tech and many
many other programs have now bubbled up
Skidmore and you know if they think
places are on the map that weren't fully
on the map in the old days so people are
coming out train and at base again in
support of break I think we all want to
gather around the campfire called the
story we want to hear a story well told
I'm interested in being with you live
that's theater or being with the cameras
but they record the story and we all go
to a movie theater I have the honor of
voting for the Oscars and the difference
in screening a movie in your den even on
a large television or going to a movie
theater is palpable I much prefer the
latter I want to be with people to hear
a good story tall and that hasn't
changed for millennia and I agree I the
other thing that's that's changed a
great deal in my career is this thing
called the reading they now pay you a
hundred dollars for 29 our reading but
you won't believe who shows up we just
did ruthless i did with Betty Buckley
myself and Leslie Kritzer I'm now doing
a piece called fashion for David zippel
with Mary testa Cristiano some of the
great singers of New York just great I
just did summer sent mom's our betters
with Michael Urie because I could never
get a chance to do it and Joanna Gleason
myself
so that's happening and the hundred
dollar a day independent film where
anybody and his mother can now almost
afford to make a film so the film
monopoly that's it the monopolies in my
time have broken down even the monopoly
of the New York Times you know it look
at the poor little New York Times I feel
badly for it you know the producers know
how to use the internet the producers
know how to do things that don't cost
anything so it's a one it's a wonderful
rich time in the entertainment world
because of the accessibility of
communication and merchandising of your
product someone that's very easily
youtube can be very interesting very
useful thank you Tony so what's the
question whoever the red do they give
the question well actually maybe we
should turn to some of these questions I
think they apply and several of them
have a resemblance to one another I'll
say one thing not acting in New York
okay concern of mine I mean I agree with
everything that I tell many very upset I
remember that when I first got to New
York when classic stage company is run
by Chris Martin and there was an
enormous pool of really wonderfully
trained and experienced leader actors
were all doing soap operas and there was
so much soap opera production in New
York people could do invariably
supportiveness as i remember a rather
good classic repertory theater
because they had day jobs doing so well
so offers now dying as a for law and
order is pretty much over some of a lot
order cookies has been you know the
secret funding source of your theater
for so they 10 years 18 years I mean
every after every day actors bio in
every play bill in the last 50 years
it's quite so and 70 on order and that's
gone and I think we're facing a lot of
competition with the immense amount of
production going on in cable television
really good stuff that's been film so
it's becoming a little bit more
difficult to get a cue tonight you know
i think it probably will always complain
about this but it's i'm discovering more
and more young actors especially who are
quite successful in film or television
but have no training is a stage actor
and don't know the kind of technical
skills that you need to write a check to
share and and have instead learn to
cognitive activate it says legitimate is
staged actually just doesn't work on
stage as well of a kind of you know to
produce behavior for the camera and you
do 50 takes and then one of them will be
the one that the director wants to use
but it's not quite the same thing as
being able to create the illusion of
spontaneity or whatever illusion is
about to be trying to create night after
night after night
tonight have the ability to really read
and analyze text and so on I think that
there is this vast industry of
undergraduate theater training which is
mostly I think clearly worthless not to
mention the way that it undermines
liberal arts education which is what the
better education should be not
vocational training not raining hard
work elevators an undergraduate there
was no theater major there's no arts
majors correct number there is now that
I think it's a great shape tourism
economy is still holding up against that
and you know the graduate schools that
can really teach acting are remarkable
but there are all that many up in the
right expenses so I think there's a bit
of a crisis i think in producing for
country of this size generate you know
generations of really well-trained later
stage actress who can do Shakespeare who
can do Johnson you can really do
difficult material and that worries me a
little bit there's not enough financial
support
misdirection in other areas well I think
this segue is very neatly into rather
provocative question how do you feel
about the takeover of a Broadway by
retellings of Hollywood movies well it
certainly does fill the seats with asses
do you think it's damaging the integrity
and creativity of the stage I don't
think brief encounters is damaging
anything I think it's clever as hell and
very interesting it breaks form for us
it I found it extremely touching and
entertaining so that I'm okay with it
but it was I thought it also has
ironically put together by a company out
of Devon and Cornwall in a barn you know
and this company has lived together for
years like like what happened in
Chekhov's time group theatre or not but
I don't know about the other stuff i
mean like singing in the rain and Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang Chitty Chitty Bang Bang
was not my cup of tea but you know I've
learned one thing and that is the
audience can tell how you rehearsed wow
if you rehearse with it's hard to be
corny but love and respect the audience
senses that if you rehearse with oh
we're going to get him on this one the
audience figures it out I don't know how
the audience figures it out I just know
that they do incredibly and that's
incredible it's just true so I don't
think it matters where the story comes
from I think that you have to rehearse
with respect for each other with respect
for the material with respect for the
people who were if you do people who are
going to come see it if you think it's a
thousand and eighty-eight miniature ATM
machines who have arrived on 45th
straight every night and you're going to
extract your hundred and twenty-five
dollars well the hell with you you
should close
if always bears repeating it so little
what is anna's activity american theatre
especially I think has all that much to
Broadway which is not as I think some
people feel the apogee the thing towards
which everyone is striving I think that
it's a it's a commercial menu its
collection sort of a spectacular through
CBM arch theaters on the planet ninety
of which have been crammed so full of
seats miserably uncomfortable to sit in
like airplanes right I've been others
have been beautifully maintained did you
jam sense is certainly done a fantastic
job with that and they're wonderful to
before member but they're not the
perfect venues for everything and most
of what's really significant and
important American theater has emerged
from elsewhere I think that's been true
for the last 20 years so yeah I mean
progress always had you know i mean when
i was first up over in angels in the
Walter Kerr I was actually leading Al
Hirschfeld who got lost backstage but
they're going to cry quite old at that
point I was leaving I ran into him and I
recognize it from his drawings and I
said can I help you every city i lost i
need to get under the stage to the other
side and i'm beating him hot up in this
place where everybody's weird cement
troughs and i say i don't know what
those are and he said oh those are co
ponds and they were used in vaudeville
when the Walter Kerr was in vaudeville
house trained seals for the sea laughs
oh my gosh but connection you have when
you go into one of those theaters in
this unitary American theater history
but it's also always been a taste
have had its version you know I you know
I don't as long as vitamin Ricky nice
people employed is fine and it might be
the beginning and God bless al pacino
you know if people are going to see
merchant because this movie star is in
it and he's a good actor and he's a
devoted actor and he loved his teacher
he loved Lee Strasburg and he hasn't
given up the fight you know for the
truth I god bless it you know that's
going to keep a lot of people employed
and bring the people from Long Island
and from New Jersey maybe to see their
first Shakespeare play you know when
when Joe DiMaggio was hitting home runs
year after year one of the little kids
came up to him and said Joe Joe why do
you keep hitting those homers and he
says I keep hitting them because
somebody ain't never seen baseball there
are several questions here some of them
are directed specifically to tova about
what would you tell an actress who's
beginning her career and other people
what do you tell young actors and also
what do you tell a young playwright how
does a young playwright here to start so
what are the challenges oh god yeah
that's okay good okay good I mean yes
all right um right pledge and
and make sure you get them produced one
way or another and think long and hard
before you better playwriting graduate
programs because i'm not sure but i
really do believe that you can teach the
age actors and directors and designers
and i'm not sure that I'd write about
this but i stopped teaching it the
Graduate the traumatic writing program
at NYU between types of wonderful
playwrights sort of going to be for
and people like that and I'm going to
drop their successes had nothing
whatsoever do anything I taught them i
mean i don't know that i don't remember
it's something you can be taught i think
it's a it's a craft that's learned
partly by studying at this evening forum
and by reading everything from ask us
onward really understanding where the
idea of narrative this particular
dialectic in this particular machine
comes from and part of it is learned in
rehearsal being around actors directors
doing their work so i become an
assistant stage manager you know props
for a show hang out another sort of get
coffee forward with director and watch
and what happens in a rehearsal room and
then and then why didn't know that
unless you can see it on the stage with
actors in an audience you're not going
to be able to develop as a playwright
because that's just an absolutely
reducible part of what i mean in the
syrup you know there are two or three
players like the thing I do
have to see their work performed of
anything but play right sleeve that it's
absolutely essential how did you see
production so if you can't get somebody
to produce your work it doesn't cost
much to do it and they're always a lot
of people who were talent around yeah
now this is where the reading might come
in reading it always been either or not
so that I mean it's a good idea to aim
for you know when I said that I had a
civil theatre company and we rented tiny
room New York and we did productions I
think it's a really important thing to
take control of that if it's not opening
up for you immediately you need it to
grow as a writer now i remember when
students would come to me asking what
graduate programs in directing they
ought to go to and say pick the one that
allows you to do the most directing i
tell an actor would Ruth Gordon told me
just tow it out and never give up never
give up you know it's what Joe Campbell
says about following your bliss but I
also tell young actors I teach up at
Yale and I think we teach what we the
way we want to be taught so I teach the
actors approach to a song I teach the
actor how to own a lyric how to own a
word as if they were birthing it in
front of you that richard rodgers and
oscar hammerstein have done their work
but they're there now and I'm with you
so I'm going to own it and skin this cat
like nobody's ever done it except for
Greg motions revival of view from the
bridge which is one of the great great
moments of monkey acts collective and
really was birth and I had the honor of
playing the f's Ribery played my son in
a walk on the moon and TCC it's just a
great actor his intelligence informs
everything I tell an actor to originate
their own work and actually I would say
do you have anything to say is there
anything you want to write and speak of
is there any way you can birth your own
work so you don't have to wait like
krill at the bottom of a food chain for
a call from other people that you are
useful or not useful to them how can you
define yourself as an artist regardless
of your employment so there's you know
this is a conundrum there but it can be
done one of the greatest things I ever
did in my career and it took me 30 years
to figure it out first year white right
an act so I did didn't acrid Wiley
Harper and we did it at the Algonquin so
that was the first thing I wrote
monologue but the best thing I did is I
acquired the rights to Golda's balcony
like even galleon my captain for now I
acquired the rights to one of my biggest
hits and i'm the producer of that show
now that's the show I take out like
white Christmas not as a seal act or a
you know a carton pony show but a way to
support myself without having to do so
fathers and I learned a lesson because
I'm looking work for Daryl Roth whom I
love and I learned that when you're a
producer of your show guess what you're
paid by the presenter you're paid for
this show then you pay to over felt you
you pay her minimum send that ten
percent of that to your agent but you're
paid for the show in the thousands of
dollars and you make a living and your
bloody deserve it and there's no you
know it's a very different situation
there are two channels going on what I
love it it's my first foray into
business you know business so I would
also suggest to an actor to to try to
originate their work try you know and
you reach for the stars you can land on
the roof you reach for the roof you
never get off the ground that's what I
would say all right by the way direct
did you want to contribute to that in
any way no I just to say that that all
the training and the everything is so
codified now and and I just tell you and
people don't ask for permission which is
what you're both saying don't ask for
permission just go do it just to bribe
the janitors with cheap wine to let me
stay and work late I wasn't supposed to
be directing
ten o'clock at night they wanted to
close the building where Juilliard I
gave away a lot of Thunderbird go into i
was looking at private fund an Oscar
acceptance speech about two weeks ago
and we came across with his acceptance
speech when she won the Oscar for
Rosemary's Baby and she was what like a
yes to me Oh GRE ridden all these things
across contain inch again yeah I'd like
an Illinois in 1906 with China with
Lincoln got the ostriches I just can't
tell you how encouraging she was the
maid of honor at my wedding and she said
I'll never forget it tova can I cut the
dress I said what are you talking about
says well you know I broke my legs so
they're very beautiful and I'd like to
show my legs at your wedding I said my
wedding my wedding her and she wore her
long down and she was a matron of our
joint rabbi rabbi when do I lift the
veil rabbi rabbi when do I give her the
blog but she was a scream and and a
great a great song it was a great love
affair i worked with right learned the
lapper own work learned a lot from
rosemary harris you know so what lynn
redgrave says and she probably got it
from her dad have some taste from whom
you steal whom were you're going to
steal from you know or from whom are you
going to steal as my father would say
and that to be with rosemary harris
doing three sisters I was just married
and Ian I'm three sisters with rosemary
harris and ellen burstyn so i had the
pillar of the of the actress theater I
had the pillar of British acting with
five octave range and then there was
little me in them in the middle and
Frank done left direct directing us and
I said if I can just if I just listen to
my sisters it'll all be okay I'll just
respond to them and I think who is it is
it Malcolm Gladwell that says it takes
10,000 hours to become a master so as
our life accumulates even some mediocre
actors in their youth become great
actors as when they're older because
they get their 10,000
hours and the body can no longer muscle
stuff through air substitutes for muscle
and they become more organic you know
and then if this would Japan they would
become national treasures I think on the
stage we have three national treasures
and I'd like to give them a big
to our moderator to our moderator as
well or in general akin to the piano
thank you
just a final word my name is Jeremy
Dalbir I'm the director of the Institute
for Israel and Jewish Studies the third
of this Trinity if I may use a
non-jewish expression it's a it's a
great delight to have listened to this
to this conversation I think we covered
every possible category in the course of
this and I'm hearing this i was reminded
of a novel by the iterator shalom
aleichem a novel called wandering stars
the Tony Kushner actually wrote an
introduction for its Adam translation
and in that novel which is a novel of
the theater Shalom Aleichem describes
the incredible attraction that Jews in
the shtetl had to the to the Yiddish
theater that comes to town and they see
this shell Malcolm writes this as a way
of their introduction to an outside
world to a modern world but reading this
I realized once again the kinds of
things that we all do here which is to
say that the Jewish story the discovery
of the excitement the challenge of
putting on masks and realizing that
they're only masks and you can be
whatever you want that Jewish story of
the modern world is just a story it's
just the story of what the theater does
for everybody in all times in all places
and we're delighted to see that this
group weaves together the Jewish story
the non-jury story and that the story of
the theater in this volume and in their
work so thank you again and I know that
all of you just have two questions which
are first where can i buy the book that
all these people are reading about and
the second is will the lovely panelists
agree to sign my volume if I buy it and
the answer to the first is over there
and the answer to the second is yes if
you are interested the books are on sale
from the library of america right in the
back and our panelists have very
graciously agreed to sign the volumes if
you come back up here with your your new
cotton newly bought copy and so with
that I will thank them for that and for
so much else thank you all have a good
night
you